okay I think it's time to get started my
name is Johan and I'm principal engineer
of bloom rich and I've been working for
this company we base in Mountain View
for four years it's my honor to be here
today and because this is actually the
first public park has since we open
source our job full control system code
briefly and i would like to what you see
like you know some of the challenges
some of the kind of cool ideas that we
use you know python to drive a very
complex data processing pipeline a
particularly MapReduce or how do so I
would like to spend a few slides just
basically give you a little bit
background of you know like the
challenges and the the problem we're
facing I don't want to get too much
about like the product since this is not
the main talk today but just enough so
that you know what the problems were
facing every day and also I try to make
sure that each component of the briefly
job control system is independent so
even if you didn't you don't end up
using briefly you publish your you know
can get some cool idea that you want to
do is your our data processing pipeline
a per se so that's kind of the the go
today so let's jump in directly to you
some background and briefly is actually
use as throughout the whole company for
all the stuff what we're doing and the
mission for boom breach is basically
providing a useful information as a
platform for our customers so we get a
lot of data from pixels get the traffic
data we crew our customers page we get
the feed so the pipeline is doing a lot
of things like a parsing indexing you
know get the analytics calculate traffic
everything you can imagine so um so just
for example are the pipeline of my team
we are actually calling 20 million pages
a day which generally about
like 500 gigabytes of data and we have
to pass them their own unstructured data
and we have to index them as well so
imagine this pipeline need to be
executed every day so the technology
stack we use of course it's hot do and
we don't have our fixed physical servers
and full for those who are not familiar
with a module EMR it's basically just
some in a hot tub service if you don't
have your Hadoop cluster you can just
say hey you know give me 10 machines 100
machines or whatever and then they
created this cluster for you and first
storage we use s3 Cassandra and
front-end and of course the the flow
control we use a Python briefly and a
little bit shell scripting so um this
graph shows you like the kind of the
challenge we face because we do have
like several product as you can see our
instance our for electric mattress as it
grows really fast like it's freshly so I
recently reached like seven hundred
thousands hours so this kind of
translate to like set several thousand
machine like a running every time 24 7
and this is actually good news or bad
news probably good news for amazon
because they get a lot of money up you
know three four hundred thousand four
months and it's just just for EMR and of
course bad news for us and so imagine
that if you can actually make the
MapReduce pipeline I or the cluster a
little bit efficient you actually save a
lot of money so here are the challenges
of course you know you have very complex
a lot of MapReduce and local processing
you know maybe with cycle and they're
getting from different sources like
local files remote file on f3 maybe some
sequel server and just everywhere and
customers you know may have different
requests so even if you have the same
processing pipeline you probably want to
select modify a little bit for each
customer as it's actually created a lot
of problem for us and of course the
processing costs
just you know skyrocketing it's crazy
and we're using one feature code a spot
spot instances is actually amazon allows
you to so like place a bid price to beat
you know how you know how much you want
to pay for like this particular type of
incidence so we want to use this just
basically reduce the costs throughout
the whole company and one of the biggest
problem is that once you have a very
complex MapReduce data processing
pipeline it's actually very difficult to
debug like imagine that you run a
pipeline you have to wait for an hour
before your cluster gets started and you
know after hours finish it and it just
found the problem you have to run it
again so the basically the complexity is
the enemy of the whole data processing
pipeline and you have you really need to
run in a different environment for
testing for example so before we decided
to build briefly we actually compare
like few existing system and we actually
try to use them like for example you can
write just write the make file and the
problem form a file is that you know if
you have files on f3 and it's really
difficult to check the time stamp and
then create the dependency for example
but it works you know like into some big
sin and we also try to cascading
cascading is sort of like Oh only for
Hadoop you know if you want to build
anything harder they can run locally but
the limitation is that everything is
inside one cluster which you know is not
good for us because we have like
hundreds of cluster at same time so what
happened if you want to control more
than one hop cluster can you actually do
that and another sort of like more
closed system from Spotify is called
Luigi and they do have some good stuff
but we really want to push to the
another level that would give a lot of
support to a Hadoop cluster particularly
so that that's kind of the singer we're
trying to do so the Gopher briefly is
that we really really want to create a
very complex pipeline in a very concise
language
in a way that I don't want to write a
lot of boilerplate I don't want to
create a class you know for various a
simple thing like just rung a hot do and
I don't want to deal with operational
issues because you know some cluster am
de Matteo this cluster failed because
the bootstrap it had some problem I
don't want to deal with that and I
really want to you know make this
pipeline robots and they're so you can
test it locally remotely you know every
environment it just works so this is
actually the architecture are for
briefly on top of it we have a sort of
like made up programming you can build
your own pipeline and then it goes to
the actual execution planner and then it
actually execute the job flow in
multiple thread and it actually interact
with file storage you know a map
produced driver talk to hot amazon
subota library so you don't have to deal
with the API yourself and everything
should be really really sort of like
clean and Before we jump to this
component I just want to give you a
really kind of a quick flash how I
briefly actually look like so you don't
get lost and everything is open source
so the the example I give you is
actually on github if you google Python
briefly that should be the first link
and you should find it easily so if I
just open those files we will look at
them in detail later so don't worry not
too much about the syntax itself so the
briefly pipeline look like this you
basically create an object like code
pipeline and then you define a bunch of
functions like hey you know you have a
pretty print function you know you want
to do something you can have a dump you
know sounds you want to do something you
can actually have a shell process you
want to do something with you and you
can even have a Hadoop process we'll
look at that later then what you have to
do is basically just chin them all
together like this like we have pipe 1 1
2 3
and then in the end we just basically
put everything together that's or it can
you read the very last line can people
sit behind see this clearly okay I'm not
quite sure
yeah okay so the cool thing about it is
that you know if you just think this is
like iterative program you're probably
wrong you can enable like multiple
threat so this three pipeline they can
actually run in parallel so you don't
have to even see you know is it like
Eden how many thread or like how many
clusters and how we can drive a
MapReduce cluster in a parallel fashion
exactly worse
okay so let's continue to the first
component which is the execution planner
and let's take back a little bit so to
let you know how what the intuition
comes from so people really kind of
familiar with this type of 5 pipeline I
think you know everybody use this in
shell scripting and you get some data
you sort a unique deci and then this is
actually called a histogram you know you
don't try to like I think you know
people really love this type of thing in
boom reach because it's just quick you
know if you have several gigabyte of the
data there's no problem you can just you
know get the quick analysis of how your
data look like so there are few
components if you look at the this you
know we have you know basically cat get
your source and then we have few process
sort and unique so this is kind of like
the the concept of pipeline so what the
shell script the best she'll help you to
do is basically it change the input and
output for you and just so you know
there is actually a name for this type
of sin tax code Hardman pipeline if you
wiki it it's just use this pipe or or in
an operator to chain them together so
then the question is that can we
actually use the very elegant syntax you
know similarly in in Python and of
course you know you've already seen that
the answer is yes but you know we would
probably mean to need to twist it a
little bit so first we have to change
you know originally in shell scripting
you put parameter in after space and an
impatient you want to call it in a way
like a function and of course we want to
change the input and output between two
notes so like in this example you want
to put the output of this function to
the next one so that's kinda trick you
have to do so how you can do that in
Python in a way
of course you know if you actually
return an object some object and then
you overload this pipe or or operator
then you can chain them right so that's
kind of the first intuition but then
quickly we have another problem like
this pipeline we actually have to input
and input one goes to full process and
input two goes to bar processed and then
we put them together so in this case we
really really want them to execute in
parallel so if you actually run this in
Python like a function then it this
result one need to be evaluated first
right and then before you go to the next
slide it's already evaluated so this
mess is probably not going to work you
know as what we we want so this is not
powerful enough so we don't like it so
of course the real solution is that we
need to build some sort of graph you
know like this graph basically represent
our data processing pipeline so every
single node would be some sort of
process that you can execute and then we
run our topological sort algorithm on
top of it then we figure out which one
can be actively in parallel which one
can be executed first and that's that's
sort of the thing we do with briefly so
this is actually the node object or the
class hierarchy in briefly we have note
we have process and then we have
spatialized process like java process
shell process or Hadoop process and then
we have a user-defined process if you
want to define your own and then we
provide a ways to so that you can
actually do it easily so let's look at
the the magic note object itself this is
basically a snippet of the node object
so what is a note I know there's
something that can be execute and also
it has ability to be configured like
take parameter or something sorry not
parameter but you know change
how it works and also it has ability to
check if it needs to be executed this is
the idea that from makes make file so if
you check your input and output
timestamp and then you found like your
output is actually newer than your input
then you know you don't have to execute
this so this function providers ability
to so like make the the pipeline
resumable if you run the pipeline and
something fail to change it then you can
continue to run and this is actually the
the sort of like the pipe operator or
the or operator so what do we do is that
we put this main source to the yourself
as the main source of the next subject
so when we actually build our graph with
this object then we can chain them
easily so basically what I'm saying is
that when you actually write a syntax
like this we're actually not executing
anything in Python but just build a
graph so everything you see here is
actually the object so how we do that
let's continue so the next thing is a
something in heard from notice which is
a process why we need this process is
because if we want to know something we
have to send the parameters but when you
create object they all have the similar
interface so we do need to handle all
different type of parameters so we
remember all the parameter and so later
on we can deal with it and then also we
provide a hash function so we can
generate unique names for each node and
this is also important because there are
a lot of duplications in the pipeline
like for example here we have the same
input goes to the same preprocess and
result one goes to full process and
power process so you can see the input
goes to pre-process is actually the same
right so but here we create the two
objects so without the hash value your
pipeline is not efficient because you
actually run the same thing twice
so that's kind of the thing we do in
briefly we use the hash value so that
it's equivalent to this because they
have the same value so we only evaluated
once that's that's the use for hash
value okay now let's look at one simple
Python note or a Python process if i
want to write a briefly process in a way
that we really want to make it look like
a functional style programming by
functional style means that you know you
just think like everything is a function
so if you have input data you have lines
you want to really want to process it
and you should just write a function
instead of writing a class but as the
the problem we just described in the end
we really really need to declare some
class so this is actually the term class
we declare and then we override the
execute method inside it right but you
know you probably sing like this is kind
of similar but that's because I you know
ignore a meet some of the the dirty you
know clean up here because you have to
create a constructor you have to be
always the parameter then you have to
chain them all together so this is
actually more complex but this is
conceptually you know we want to do this
so how you can do that in a sort of like
magical way you know by argument that
function to a class and thanks for the
dynamic nature of the Python programming
language we can actually do that with
the decorator so this is actually the
arm that the the wrapper are we used to
augment function into a class so here if
you destroy something as a simple our
process and what we do is that we create
a new class for you that's what you can
see here there is a inner class and
because it's inside a function
so every single time you call this
rapper Python would create a new type
for you and of course you know in the
execute function we have to chain back
to the original function you create
which is this one and then this is kind
of interesting thing is after you create
a class you don't want the class name to
be processed wrapper right so you have
to change so like a full python that you
change the font the class name to your
original function name and then put
return the back so it occupies the
global a dictionary so after this
wrapper you actually have a class called
dump and which it does sing for you so
that's kind of the cool idea we do in
briefly and of course we have several
different type of wrapper for different
type of process but as you can see we
really really want to focus at the
conciseness and so like put it in the
allegan way we don't want to think about
object-oriented programming we really
want to sink a functional so and and all
this function is the thing we care about
we don't really want to deal with the
boilerplate of the class creation okay
and similarly we can define a java
process or Java a node but instead of
handling the data inside pi song itself
this is more like kind of calling out
you just sub-process module you go out
to java and you run something like so
what is the minimum thing you need to
execute in external Java process you
need to know of where you get the input
file you need to know where you put the
output right and of course you need to
know the class name and then you can run
everything and probably class pass as
well so in the function what you declare
is not the actual execution of the the
logic it's actually just you know where
is the Java class or where is a jar you
are going to go so with a similar wrap
are instead of override the the execute
function we actually override the
configure function so that function
basically is a provider of some
information like how to execute the
eternal Java process here and we augment
the function to a class again and then
we can use that function to get the the
key of parameters we need to execute a
Java so we so combined it's actually
possible to just assign it back to a
variable because everything now is a
objector force to you some process or
catch some process then you can assign
it to a variable so if you want to
branch you have some sort of data and
then you want to branch the pipeline
what you need to do is like just put the
data and then to to process foo and bar
then you have to do two targets then you
can run your pipeline or if you have
emerged some a process that can take
parameter like result one a result to
and briefly would use the type dynamic
type to figure out oh you actually have
a type that is briefly process so then
it build a dependency on top of it so
when you actually execute this one and
then you do a trace back to result one
and result to and trace back to all this
to pipeline so then you actually figure
out the whole graph so you run
topological sort and then you can run
things in parallel so no let's just go
back a little bit again to our demo this
is actually the installation process we
put it on github as well so if you want
to try please you know go ahead but we
only test it down you bum to Linux so if
you test on Mac OS or Windows and you
figure out there is some problem please
let us know so but unfortunately this is
only a platform we tested
so let's jump back to the example so
first you know you just import briefly
library and like this and then you
create a pipeline here are a bunch of
simple process in Python so you can
print it out you can dump it and then
this is the one that you split every
single line into words so it's it's
really simple and here is another one
code shell process that if you really
want to run a shell and that its
external command you can actually do
this and the good thing about briefly is
that we provide a lot of protection for
example you can set the timeout if this
process is more than is that good more
than 10 seconds then we'll cure that as
failure then briefly will retry that so
any type of failure you know exception
and you know how to class or failure
then we will retry that so you can make
sure that your pipeline is really really
real fast you know you don't want some
tiny thing to fail your whole pipeline
after in a few hours of execution so
then this is some function that we
created a lot of pipeline
like get date and we call that the
briefly process so you create a 5.5
pipelines in parallel and then you chain
them together so how does this work
let's just run it oh uh just a little
bit so two rung it you just rung it like
a regular Python program there is
nothing spatial it's actually made hot
programming so your Python program is
still Python so it's not some magic here
but we provide another configuration
file so a lot of things you can change
we will see that in a bit and basically
just give you some input like you know
how many threads you run how many times
you want to retry and you can have your
own definition like input dark where you
get the input that's something you can
get so for example this is this is
actually where we get the input and
let's wrap it so for the first pipeline
what do we do is that we get the input
file and then we feel that it like a
group like a run your grip and then we
find some pattern and then we print it
out and for second pipeline we want to
get a list of date and then printed like
running a shell and the third pipeline
we actually want to split every single
line into words and then we want to
count it unique and lies that what we'd
like what we did with a huge grin
pipeline and sort it and head in a five
so it's pretty straightforward but in
the end we want to put all the data all
together and then print it out and this
is actually our final target so we just
execute it and that's our final output
so if we run it then we will see that
this is actually the result of first
pipeline and this is the second pipeline
and this is the third pipeline and if we
actually change the configuration for
example but we probably cannot see it
like wrong in three threat instead of a
single thread then we can run it again
since we can't get it it so there's no
difference at all so it's pretty easy
for you to just scale up
so it's actually dung behind the scene
so every sing it's an it's not so when
we actually do this pipe operator so
what we do is that for every process we
create an output file for you so we use
disk as a temporary location but this is
for local process but if there is super
hot due process then we use s3 and we're
talk about that later in the file
abstraction layer so we basically see
the s3 and local file system as the same
thing so we can use s3 and the local
file as sort of like a buffer for you in
between and this is important for
debugging because you know some pipeline
you really want to figure out the data
in the middle and it's just a mechanism
because we cannot chin for example local
process to how to process directly you
definitely need to put the file on s3
before you can run how to break them or
HDFS cool any other question no ok so
now we can do something uh you know a
little bit just kind of modify a little
bit if we do have you know our own
configuration say hey you know I want to
test this pipeline but this is
production pipeline so I really don't
want to run the whole thing you know I
really want to have my own configuration
so what you can do is basically just
create your own configuration and then
you can run it again so let's do this
for example let's say if I have my own
input ok and then let's go at the test
dot the conf okay and then we can just
created this file
cold test stock text for example and
then let's just put some data here so
once you do that and then you can run it
again then you see your data is already
so imagine that you have a very complex
how to pipeline and then you want to run
it with different source different
smaller input data you don't really need
to change the original configuration
file so what you need to do is provide
your own small modification of it and
then you can run it locally for testing
or debugging purpose so that's kind of
the thing we do a lot in boom reach
because you really don't want to run a
very large cluster for for debugging
before you you are pretty sure that
everything is working correctly any
questions
cool so let's move on to the next topic
so now we've already seen some poise
data pipeline so what happens next is
that you know you get more steps maybe
ten step 20 steps and you definitely
cannot run everything locally you have
to you know just go you know our to
wrong Hadoop so you need more computing
power and by you know computer bottom
means you know this distributed
computing so to do that first you have
to abstract your file system or storage
layer because if everything is a local
file then your your data pipeline is
pretty much in a fix to running
everything locally so in order to do
that we leverage another open source
project code s for CMD basically this is
our previous open source project we use
that to interact with Amazon s3 so
everything can be uploaded or download
automatically and it's really important
for us to check the timestamp so when we
compare like a local file to a remote
file and am alone require you to set the
time and date correctly or we see in
certain arrow so when you access the
file s3 you can pretty sure that your
clock locally is kind of synchronized to
the clock on s3 and of course you know
in in file the timestamp for files
they're all in UTC or unique so you can
just compare them at directly so we do
this type of implicit file transfer when
you have a local process and a remote
process and we would upload and download
the file automatically for you this
basically enable you to our tests Hadoop
locally imagine that if you have a
pipeline and that you have something
code upload in the middle then your
pipeline is really not flexible because
when you run locally then you have to
ignore that step right
and this is really useful for analytics
when you run analytics or something
MapReduce in the end the data could be
very small you probably just don't want
to download a few files you know summary
to check the end result and this is uh
the use case for that and it's also
possible to upload the configurations
for your Hadoop process and we will see
that in a bit so this is basically the
idea if your pipeline is some Java
process chained to a Hadoop process and
it's flexible you can run the locally or
you can run it there remotely with EMR
so if you were ready wrong to run on
elected you sent briefly automatically
insert upload note in the middle for you
implicitly so you don't have to deal
with the ugliness of you know upload and
download this type of see cool
currently we don't but because we
actually talked to EMR directly the
reason we are not talking directly to
HDFS which is in our plan to do is we
want to support the Hadoop to API
directly if you are running your own
cluster you are provisioning your own
cluster then you have HD f entrance then
you can actually talk to your HD f a
cluster directly but unfortunately this
is not the youths case in bloom reach so
that's why I we don't have that today
but we are planning to do that any other
questions ok so sorry this is kind of
the another open source project so if
you actually google a python is for
comment you can actually see it's
actually a replacement for s3 come in so
because we found a lot of problem with
s3 comment for example you cannot
actually the multipole thread it has
problem to upload or download five files
more than five gigabytes in the past
newer version probably they already
solve that and we handle again in a
multiple Surette multiple connection
download correctly so basically this is
kind of the replacement for as you come
in so i go to you boom rich open source
the kid on github then you can see this
open source project it actually get more
attraction because we actually open
sources two years ago so a lot of people
do something with it like encryption you
know modified to run on Windows a lot of
interesting stuff but yeah
cool so now let's jump to another
interesting component coda property
collection the similar concept a lot of
system has that like Hadoop or a spark
they all have their own configuration
system why this configuration is
important is because if you have several
functions you know function a code
function behold function C or like it's
just critical each other it's really
kind of annoying to pass those
information along with it so for those
of you are familiar with Hadoop then you
can set the conf or a configuration for
that but they're just not good enough
because python is a dynamically language
so we really want to bring out a good
part of python so what does that mean is
that we we really don't want to write
something like this because if you have
a property k why not just you know that
K directly Python allows you to do that
so you don't really need to handle a the
ugliness of court and ask a square
bracket and then a double quote this you
know I really hate this time you know
typing a lot of character and also you
can package it you know your
configuration in a sort of like
serialization way and imagine that if
you want to handle your configuration in
a different programming language that in
Java and you can do that easily because
our for marriage is an M equals some
JSON and this gives you a lot of power
you can just you know use any language
which has a json parser then you can
parse it directly and you don't have to
deal with escaping for example if you
actually write your own parser you know
remove the double quote then you have a
lot of problem like / and / t then you
have handled that correctly and jason
also provide like lists or dictionary so
you can actually use it out of the box
so
another important feature for briefly
configuration is that it's a
hierarchical but hierarchical means that
we can have something that something
that's something you know continuously
so you can have hot do binary you can
have EMR cluster name and then you can
put all your poverty settings all
together so they're basically resolve
recursively and you can actually put all
your important configuration into one
single file which is sure across your
production pipeline or your testing
pipeline and people want to run their
personal pipeline they just millennial
inherited it and then imported them or
just modify a little bit the give us a
lot of power to run the same pipeline in
a different environment also we get a
very interesting idea from shell
scripting code string interpolation and
I cannot tell you how important this is
because if you have a lot of paths input
pass out footpaths if you really don't
want to repeat it over and over again so
a very elegant way is basically put a
base pass and then you can have input
output path based on this path and maybe
some other pet pass based on your output
pass for example and so in this case you
have the flexibility to overwrite any of
it and you yes
oh okay stick here okay thank you that's
okay so for example if you want to run
some pipeline locally you want to move
everything then you just replace base
pass right if you watch just want to
modify one then you can still do that so
this gives you a lot of flexibility in a
trench is a pipeline you you you want to
run and this actually grows really fast
you for a very complex pipeline you
probably have more than hundred settings
so you know tiny things here a little
bit there it's it just just a complexity
you have to deal with and everything is
actually lazily evaluated which means
that when we actually get the value it
then interpolate and get the value from
the original string and recursively
doing this on til it gets a value so you
don't need to worry about which one is
defined first which is one is defined
later so you can basically put in any
order and they're just running things
correctly so how did we do that in in
python is basically we hack into the the
object model so for those who are
familiar with Python object they provide
a lot of things like underscore
underscore get attribute and set
attribute so this to magic method when
you actually intercept them it's
actually call invoked when you have like
friggin of some object that a or dot B
and your get attribute would be code
when you try to get the belly so when
this function is cold then we intercept
them and then translate and to get the
value from our dictionary internally and
vice versa when you set the value then
we have to do the rising recursively so
that's the metric we do with Python
rtti so that you can use the symbol
directly and and of course we want to
you know filter out the underscore
underscore seeing so that we don't mess
around with the original essential
attribute for the Python object and then
there are a lot of default property are
provided by briefly so it's a good
reference to just take a quick look and
to see what's provided it's also a very
good reference if you want to see what
you can change your what that you can do
with it it's in default dot P Y so this
property is loaded by default for all
the pipelines and you can see you can
change boot directory you can set you
know how many time you want to retry for
failure retry delay for example and how
many thread you know this is important
for multi-threaded execution debug mode
and for shell exclusion how many shell
you can run in parallel so these tiny
things like you can configure and Java
you know how many external Java process
you want to limit and you know for how
do you can set the the runner you know
you want to run it locally you want to
run our EMR and where it's a binary if
you run it locally and this bunch of
stuff is for Amazon EMR cluster so you
basically just set it and or you can use
the default value you don't have to
change anything and if you use cubo
which is another provider for Hadoop
then you just set the hotdog runner
equals the cube oh you don't even need
to change your pipeline and then it just
run directly on Cuba so that's kind of
like the goal we're trying to do is
separate your pipeline logic with this
little tiny dirty operational logic
which you need to be always cool
so that's the property part they would
provide you a property collection you
can modify it you can serialize it and
now we have the ability to sort of like
go into the mapreduce a driver which is
kinda the the biggest benefit of briefly
we spend a lot of time to play with
amazon EMR to give you the most of it so
what are the issues we are facing with
Hadoop the biggest nightmare is probably
not some park it's actually the job
that's running forever so embarrassingly
in blue Maurice you can probably see
like some percentage like cluster just
stuck so this is horrible you know
imagine that in Java you might have like
memory leak our resource leak not memory
leak and but we are talking about
cluster leak so you can leak cluster
because if you don't handle it correctly
then no one actually destroy your
cluster then your class or running
forever and basically they're costing
you money and then no one noticed that
and in the end of month gosh you know
it's it's a bill so it's just bad and
again it's difficult to test on those
environments so we really need to test
with different type of do provider on
Cuba on our EMR so how do you define a
Hadoop process in briefly very similar
to java process so the minimum seem we
need sorry I cannot go there there's a
main class so for those were not
familiar with the role uh-huh do it's
basically imagine that it's like the
Java so you have a jar file you sent to
Hadoop cluster and they will run your
class so it's exactly similar or exactly
the same to Java process and you have to
set the input and output you know either
on f3 or locally so then you can run it
and if you run the change it different
configuration local or a remote then you
just change the configuration so nothing
changed in you
code and logic you know when you want to
run a different environment and default
values are in default WI the interesting
thing happened here is that we provide a
resource management most of the pipeline
management or job flow control flow
system allows you to create a single
cluster but here we're dealing with
multiple cluster if you have 100 machine
you can actually create one cluster with
100 machine or you can devise sub
divided them into 10 cluster with Ken
machine and then you have the
flexibility if some cluster has some
problem that you switch your job to
other cluster but that's actually the
thing we we want to do to get the
robustness out of the box sorry yes
it's actually the question is that is
this a base on top of what yarn right
which is how to resource scheduler the
answer is not it's actually implemented
natively in briefly because we actually
control multiple cluster so imagine
Hadoop to point oh they're basically
just think think about this is a
management of a single cluster but on
Amazon alack MapReduce what happens if
you just you only have one cluster and
it gets killed then there is no way you
can handle that you know in yarn
directly or you have to heck it and then
to handle multiple classroom so briefly
is actually a layer on top of them to
handle multiple cluster does that make
sense to you so we're trying to sort
like now go out of it because not
everybody use Hadoop 2.0 but you know
eventually we will support that and
maybe just every single job or the job
to send into one cluster if that's what
you want then we can have another
resource management basically just
that's nothing but send all the job to a
one single cluster but here we are
talking about multiple clusters
currently we don't again if it's because
in boom reach our MapReduce or hot boob
job is in Row Java so we just use Java
directly and we send a jar to EMR
cluster but we are trying to wrap for
example apache spark and the other type
of jobs as well but we haven't tried a
peek or any type of other type of job
cool now I want to show you a very soul
like example if we do have this type of
flow and we want to run in multiple
thread in a more than three threats and
we have allowance too we can create a to
EMR cluster so what happens in briefly
resource management so imagine this s is
some local job you have to run you know
it might take an hour you might be
taking like five minutes and all those h
12 h 5 they are hot boob jobs so first
you have to execute your local job there
is no way that you can avoid it because
this is our the dependency you know for
this 3 job so after this one finish you
know simultaneously this three sinks can
be started right away because you have
more than one thread so let's break it
into this separately but remember those
freezing actually happened at the same
moment so the job one the extra one had
the one want to execute something on EMR
so it talks to you the classroom manager
and we found like oh there is actually a
empty slot for that so it would occupy
that slot say oh I want to you know run
each one and this slot will figure out
that oh there is no current a cluster
associate with that so it would talk to
Amazon EMR through portal library and
create this cluster for you so you don't
have to handle this you know both of API
is ugly and it just just gets created so
now this h1 would start to execute an
EMR cluster and similarly for h2 you
found this empty slot and then oh there
is no EMR associate with this slot so it
will create another one so now
interesting thing happened to h3 because
there is no available slot so it this
thread would be blocked and it just
basically wait until any slot is
available so this allows you to control
like
how many cluster you want to create EMR
so you see like this cluster they
basically can multiply the wrong
multiple job and it's really efficient
because you know we want to share this
same cluster for all your pipeline we
don't want them to just you know run a
single job and let's imagine that h2
just completed so so once this job
completed this slot won't kill this
cluster right away and we wait for like
10 minutes because we know there might
be a job once you get this a cluster and
execute something right away like h3 so
in this case it's just reboot the thread
would be unblock and then get the the
slot and execute right away and then h1
finished but at this point we cannot
kill Mr cluster one again we have to
wait for a while 10 minutes and then
this cluster it gets killed so this
basically reduce the cause because we
only have one job we want to execute at
this moment and h3 continue to run you
know maybe an hour or whatever and then
X for a takeover so in this case when h4
try to pick the empty slot it will try
to pick the one with currently with the
running cluster we use the priority
queue here so we won't get this empty
slot by default because if edge for gets
this empty slot and you need to create
another cluster which is not efficient
and then similar for h5 and after
everything is done then all the clusters
are destroyed and one important thing in
briefly is that we handle all the type
of failures and exception for example
control C interrupted correctly so when
you actually click ctrl C with your
briefly process we release all the
resources so we have to you know destroy
all the clutter for you a lot of
pipeline controller doesn't handle this
correctly so so you will leak a class
in some situation so the the next course
thing is that we use spot instance
because we want to beat in a some prices
and then we want to solve like minimal
it minimize the cost so we have a
bidding strategy you can set briefly so
originally you want to be the very low
price and then if it gets killed and
then you want to be the higher price and
this can be configured in properties as
well so you can have your own strategy
you know how you want to bid if you said
the price of zero then we were used on
the main prize on the main cluster which
is you know really expensive but it
won't get cute so this is how it works
so imagine that originally we beat the
two cluster with just 20 cents and
they're just running and suddenly for
some reason one cluster gets killed
because the spot users price goes up and
but the interesting thing on Amazon is
that not all your classes would get gets
killed at the same time maybe someone
just you know how pdu and for a certain
capacity so it's not necessary that the
the same beating the cluster we send
beating price what it gets killed
simultaneously so let's say this cluster
gets killed so the [ __ ] would actually
send the exception of back to the
original our thread so now the thread
gets a failure and it will retry again
based on our settings how many times you
want to retry so but remember h3 is also
blocking so in Python the the resource
manager basically is actually a queue
like system so h3 would actually get
this slot first and it will figure out
oh there's an empty slot so it will
continue to execute but H 1 will be
plugged this is actually good for us
because for some failed job you want to
try later you won't want to try right
away maybe you know let someone else to
execute execute first that's kind of the
causing but here in this case because
the slot actually remember is previous
beating price so it will actually try to
be
with a higher price so it will try to
create another cluster which is in a
class of one prime with a higher beating
price so briefly also handle this for
you so and this is all running under the
hood and you don't have to worry about
that once you set this correctly so now
we have everything yes
yes so let's show you in this demo now
we want to run some Hadoop pipeline but
again we just want to run either locally
because I don't want to use the company
account to run a cluster it probably
takes 40 minutes to provision so I
cannot show you in time so for a Hadoop
pipeline let's see you have a bunch of
configuration like I do in a binary
where you want to run the jar etc and as
the question is one where you can set
the policy for EMR again it's in default
IP why if you want to take a look
so the bidding price policy is here so
it's basically just a list so we if you
want to bid any type of instance say m1
extra large and you can set your pricing
policy here 0.8 means the multi are
basically 0.8 times the original and the
main prize is your bidding price so we
are saying that the first time we're
trying to bid with lower price and the
second time we're trying to bid 1.5
times on the main prize and the third
time if we fail twice then we use on the
main cluster we don't want to bid
anymore so that's you know our policy
and you can configure it as a policy in
your configuration file for your
production pipeline you want to do this
policy for your testing or debugging
pipeline you probably just want to use
on the main price directly because you
don't want to waste time if you know
you're debugging clusters fail over and
over again it's just basically wasting
time for your debugging process cool so
now let's go back to our Hut do pipeline
it's actually simpler so again we have
few three simple process you can have
high some process if you want to handle
any type of data and you know this is
this one just again gets a word out and
then emit the count and only allow the
English words had no other spatial
character so here is a Hadoop process we
want to define this is actually the
example are in Hadoop distribution so
this allows you to just download how to
pan wrong it directly this is just a
demo and but if you have your own haboob
jobs just replace this with your own
configuration and then you can run it
and so the pipeline is really simple you
get from the same
file you run this word count which is
Hadoop job and then you run some local a
Python process and then again you sort
and then you had the first 10 line and
then you've done so let's try to run
this sorry
so it probably takes five seconds you
know it launching hot do then then it
sorting stuff and then you can see the
result here it's already so if you
actually go to the Buda rectory as we
talked earlier every single process has
a separate a log file so if you look at
this word count log you can actually see
the output from the how to process so
this is actually the full log of how to
process you just execute it cool now the
less part just two slides is the log
structure once we get to the complex
pipeline there are hundreds of steps
it's just really painful to run it every
day debugging so we really need to put
all the log file into one location so
you can easily find it and this
basically is based on our hash value for
each process and you can find that
easily and you can also change boot
directly if you want the best practice
for briefly pipeline is actually build
small pipeline to drive large pipeline
the idea is really similar like our
engine you have a motor to drive
something which is bigger imagine that
if your pipeline need to get a lot of
configuration maybe from your a
configured management system or some
sequel file before you can run the full
pipeline it's really difficult to mix
everything together you probably want to
run a small pipeline to get other
configuration and put into one file you
know serialize it so you can figure out
what's going to be executed on a larger
pipeline so we actually did this
practice a lot in bloom reach to get all
the configuration first and soon realize
it to a local file and then we send this
file and then use this configuration as
planned to run your MapReduce pipeline
maybe with 100 class 100
our customers in all together so that's
kind of the the best practice of that
who I think that concludes our talk
again this is not the project done by
one person I really want to use this
chance to say thank you to a lot of
contributors and again this is the first
time so I don't know if this too much or
is it too high level or because we do
have a lot of operational experience
with electing my produce so we try to
overcome those operational issue but on
the other hand we also want to bring the
goodness of functional programming into
our pipeline construction so that's kind
of the end go uh because i really like a
functional programming on top of
object-oriented programming cool yes
the this wives really done a year ago so
after a year then last month's we we
open source it so for my pipeline is
already running for a year really really
without you know any major instance
imagine that in the past you know every
single night or like once or twice a
week you get a pager because some you
know MapReduce fail and there's a lot of
operational issues either a spot
instance you know or bootstrap action
fail and it you know in the end people
just cannot handle the complexity either
your pipeline is too complex or there
are too many operational issues so we
really want to separate this from the
business logic and the operational
issues so people can actually focus on
the data or the logic they are
processing so we run in this for one
year we handle more than a 100 cluster
that every day I think we're really
happy with it so that's the reason we
hope has source it
the failure still happened but because
it is retried again you know it bit
higher so you don't actually see it I
really see it maybe once you know every
two or three months but it's rare
because we can actually run they're very
efficient yeah and it's felt no problem
please retry right it doesn't need to
fail the whole pipeline just because of
one tiny failure yes you mean the the
Hadoop perfect it particularly oh so
again this goes back to how we actually
build the graph so if we have this type
of graph the first thing we do is run a
topological sort so knit then we know
which one can be executed first and
after that because we have multiple
threads so you actually need to figure
out for example which one does and have
the the in link for example if you
actually completed s right we actually
remove the S note and then you know from
s know there is actually called bridge
no two other no this is actually a graph
algorithm so from here you can actually
figure out this three note can be
activated simultaneously then you
actually have a shred pool then you can
assign thread pool to each one and this
is actually set in your configuration
like how many thread you want to execute
totally for your briefly pipeline yes
yeah yes so that's why in briefly
configuration you see that we always
have time out we actually have a step
timeout or total a cluster timeout so
you can set this step timeout for
example each job you can run like 12
hour maximum if you know that your job
should not you know run over two hours
you can set it for four hours then you
can you know sleep you know nicely every
every night because you know if it's
something wrong more than four hours you
definitely know there is something wrong
with cluster either the provisioning is
not correct or all some instance gets
killed you know if you want to 10
machine cluster maybe you only get one
so that's the reason why it's running
really slow or some other issue and
similar for all the local process you
definitely need to set timeout for each
process so that you can kill them and
retry so that's kind of the kefir
briefly that we can run since rope in a
robust way yes
it's definitely not so ah that's the
benefit for briefly is that you want to
create a cluster and share it you know
as much as possible if you just create a
cluster for each job then it's really
not efficient so the idea for briefly is
that you can create a fixed number of
cluster said you know to five or ten and
run hundreds of job you know across name
so you get maximum efficiency of
government they're not but you can
configure it every single cluster is
independent so on am alone every cluster
has its own HDFS on top of it so if you
really want to share data you have to
write your Hadoop process pointing to
the same hdf a cluster so this is
actually different concept in Cuba you
can actually do that because they keep a
small HDFS cluster for you but this is
kind of outside the configuration or the
premise of briefly pipeline but you can
do that but not in briefly today
yes but in numerous remember there is
actually another scenario in Amazon is
that you can actually put your data s 3
s 3 is actually always available so you
know if you actually have a lot of data
you run to run a multiple cluster you
can still do that you've all your data
is on f3 does that make okay yes yes and
if you exactly and if you want to copy
from s3 to HDFS you can also do that in
a way that you have to do it yourself
any other questions cool thank you I
Cinco we and a little bit earlier but
really appreciate that so if you have
any comments you use it and you found
any problem please email me and you know
or post it on the github forum and I
would be happy to answer all the
questions that you have if you have
later thank you